et on commence avec la visite surprise
de la promo saison 1 qui a remonté les
marches du château et les a également
redescendu
[Musique]
fais le mort sur Tik Tok et cela dure
depuis un an tous les jours ce
restaurateur du Kentucky se met en scène
inerte dans une rivière dans la rue sur
un banc ou dans son salon un défi assez
macabre pour tenter de décrocher un rôle
et cela a fonctionné un jour l'homme de
42 ans s'est mis à parler sur son compte
parce qu'il a été repéré par l'équipe
d'une série télé policière dans laquelle
il a pu jouer un cadavre peut-être le
début d'une carrière à Hollywood
des bananes roulantes mais aussi
d'inquiétantes disparition
tu as le choix ma chaussure elles sont
toujours
à 49 ans il n'a jamais habité ailleurs
que dans ce paradis
et puisqu'on y est si bien ce grand
adolescent il vit toujours avec sa maman
Lucette 87 ans
je mets de la musique et bien c'est
samedi Valentino Compass voilà
c'est là ça met bonne numéro oui
l'accordéon et Sandy Valentino il y a
pas mieux que la famille remède vous
prenez un billet de banque mettez un peu
de poudre magique un peu pour moi je
fais aussi de la télévision et vous
pardon pour cette vanne bienvenue
qui faisait sa discute et il y avait un
truc qui m'avait chopé en tant que gamin
c'est que à la fin il serait la main de
tout le monde il y avait les 10
personnes vous savez cette émission et
c'est vrai que au début le générique de
fin part et sert la main de la première
de la deuxième il voit qu'il est à
l'antenne de la troisième de la 4e et
dès qu'il voit qu'il est plus à
l'antenne et que je dirais qu'il a fini
les 4 derniers hop bah mais ça il se
barre oui ça s'appelle l'animateur parce
que les médias oui je trouve que les
médias jouent un rôle
joue un rôle dévastateur dans les
relations humaines moi je pense je
prends souvent pour référence par
exemple ma grand-mère qui est en
Bretagne et qui a pas accès à certaines
connaissances ou certaines choses qui
peuvent pas se passer par une sorte de
Paris à regarder BFM TV elle devient
raciste c'est une réalité
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai mais alors si
elle va sur cnews
j'en ai déjà parlé ça valait pas
animateur ça s'appelle le groupe
attends
il y a une différence entre Reichman
n'est pas le pire
de la rue après voilà hors caméra ne
plus serrer la main à la troisième
personne ça s'appelle pas
[Musique]
qui c'est à toi ça c'est des chansons
françaises des chansons
c'est une chanson de l'un de vous
cascade
c'est toi Pascal c'est possible
ça me rappelle moi je dirais que c'est
parce que
pas du tout
[Musique]
dans le public j'avais peur de faire une
chaîne alors je te rassure d'abord
je veux dire une chose à l'image de
Shine c'est un petit clin d'oeil on
l'aime on l'aime notre ami c'est mon ami
Ayem on a fait beaucoup aussi des
prestations
en sortant de Secret Story après j'avais
arrêté quand j'étais en couple parce
qu'il supportait pas ça mais j'en ai
fait beaucoup et oui je j'étais très
très bien payée j'ai été payé une fois
jusqu'à 8000 euros
en sortant de Secret Story
je veux dire quelque chose ça tu pourras
jamais le répéter avant si le public
veut il prend dans ses bras s'il veut
pas il te laisse te casser la gueule
c'est la vie
[Applaudissements]
j'ai bien cette chanson en tout cas j'ai
pas de qui c'est mais
que tu me
meurs pour ce que je suis ah ouais c'est
ça
[Musique]
que tu sois la même il y a 8 ans il y a
M6 qui m'a contacté pour faire un
reportage dans mon quartier dans mon
quartier à Évreux qu'un quartier
difficile etc ou les portes souffrent
pas si facilement que ça il m'avait
appelé pour faire un reportage pour
redorer l'image des quartiers populaires
donc il m'avait appelé tremielleux les
vrais sacs de merde oui ça va être super
vous allez voir on va donner une image
extraordinaire
et quand ils sont arrivés sur place
l'attention était complètement
différente pour vous la tentation de
devenir un escroc elle existe quand on
est un médecin
j'ai essayé mais il y a des jeunes
roumaines et autres qui étaient plus
fortes que moi parce qu'elles étaient en
banque
[Rires]
déjà les escrocs
il me faut des barbus
et je lui dis mais pourquoi il y en a
mais il y a pas que ça elle me dit oui
mais c'est ça qui vendent non plus elle
a ramené une dame à son balcon voilé
elle a fait un plan à dire mettez-vous
comme ça au balcon ça fait très Coco
Chanel c'est super
elle a payé des gamins pour qu'ils
disent des choses devant la caméra
donc moi pour moi oui les médias ont un
rôle de dévastateur dans la société vous
dites que le matin vous vous levez et là
vous commencez l'écriture automatique
moi je veux que vous me donniez des
astuces je suis devant ma télé je veux
dire moi aussi j'ai envie d'écrire ou
j'ai envie d'être connecté comme ça
donnez moi une un petit truc mais si je
veux dire ce qu'il faut faire ça va pas
vous plaire mais pourquoi il faut
éteindre la télé
[Applaudissements]